NARRATOR: Albuquerque,
New Mexico.
Ancient astronaut theorist,
Giorgio Tsoukalos,
is at the home of
Linda Moulton Howe.
After examining all of
the material related
to the Majestic 12, she
believes that the most
compelling documents
are those that
surfaced in Maryland in 1994.
This, to me, this is the best
document that's been leaked.
It's called Restricted
SOM1-01, Majestic 12 Group.
And all of us, when we first
saw that title, Extraterrestrial
Entities and Technology,
Recovery and Disposal, one
of the first things that
everybody wanted to do
was find out, OK, did they
use this stamp in 1954
from the war office.
Turns out that they did, all
the way up until the 60s.
And one of the more
important pieces I think
is, as you go through here,
they found in a government
printing office--
take a look at this--
this is from a blow up,
where they were doing a test.
And look at this
"unauthorized", and look
at what happens to that z.
It raises slightly.
- Right.
So Bob went to the
government printing office
and found a guy named McCarter,
who was printing in the GPO
in Washington DC in 1954.
And he took one
look at this text,
and he said this was
done on monotype.
I used it.
And the z would collect
dust, and that's
why the z's would print raised.
So different steps
have been taken
to authenticate this document.
- Yes.
The fellow I spoke
to, he, fortunately,
had been a long, long time
employee of the public printer
and had actually worked on the
kind of presses that he thought
were appropriate
for this document.
He said based on
the printing, I'd
say it clearly
was printed on one
of the presses in this
building or in this basement
of the Pentagon in 1954,
which is what it says.
And then when you
start getting into what
is in this book, you
have the illustrations
and sketches of four
different categories
of different craft UFOs.
And on this page,
here are the disks.
Here is a long,
cigar shape, which
is described in this
document, as being
up to 1,000 feet in diameter.
And then, this one, the
ice cream cone, and this,
the triangle, and there
is a paragraph in here
that implies that we are dealing
with collaboration, that there
must be some agreement
between the United States
and the extraterrestrials.
Really?
LINDA MOULTON HOWE:
There is on this page 17,
it's under Chapter
5, and it goes
into a, encounters initiated
by the extraterrestrial
biological entities.
Possible contact may take
place as a result of overtures
by the entities themselves.
In these instances, it is
anticipated that encounters
will take place at
military installations
or other obscure locations
selected by mutual agreement.
This is--
GIORGIO TSOUKALOS: By mutual?
LINDA MOULTON HOWE: Yeah.
1954.
NARRATOR: According to
the Majestic 12 documents,
the men who made up this group
and were in communication
with beings from
other worlds included
top scientists,
government officials,
and high-ranking
military personnel.
In 1954, President
Eisenhower supposedly
met with extraterrestrials
in Palm Springs
at Edwards Air Force Base,
otherwise known as Muroc.
And there's a lot of
whistleblower testimony about
his presence at this meeting.
He was just as probably
alarmed or shocked as anybody,
you know, realizing
the larger picture.
But with all the
whistleblower testimony
about these
different encounters,
I pretty much side on the
fact that he did make contact.